Et bien bonjour, je suis avec Maxenss, Sofyan et Seb, bienvenue les amis!
Hello!
Nous allons jouer à un jeu aujourd'hui...
Alors il ya très peu d'ambiance dans ce début de vidéo
*Rires Intensifs*
Le silence était là *lol*
On va jouer à un jeu où on va tester votre improvisation
Donc tu fais du doublage
Ouais
Tu as fais du doublage...
Tu as fais du doublage
*Oui.
Euh, vous avez du IMPROVISER devant une séquence okay?
*Ouais collectif*
Là vous allez faire la même chose, mais à l'écrit!
Ça va être sous forme de sous-titres
ON a jouer à ce jeu avec McFly et Carlitos et le Grand JD la dernière fois
C'était très amusant
Ça a énormément plu aux gens
Donc j'ai décidé de vous inviter et vous avez gentiment accepté
PLAY
C'est la première Game, l'indulgence sera présente ne vous en faites pas *Extrait*
OKAY
"Écoutez chevaliers, nahnahnahnahnah"
Là vous devez trouver le...
HAHAHA ILS SONT TOUS CONCENTRÉS C'EST TROP OUF
*Seb* Attends Attends! *Lucas*Ah ils parlent pas les mecs!!
Ils veulent être trop bon, c'est génial!
HAHAHA
TOUT LE MONDE EST PRET?
OUI
OKAY c'est parti
*Rires Intensifs*
Qui a mit ça?
*Seb* C'est moi
AHH c'est bien
OHHHHH
*Sofyan* ÇA c'est toi! Ça c'est toi les emojis!
*rires*
C'était moi...Ça m'a fait plaisir
*Rires intensifs*
BIEN BIEN BIEN BIEN
AHH On commence bien, on commence bien!
*Sofyan* C'est dur!
OKAY Maintenant ça va être un journal les gars, ça va être une photo OKAY?
Ok
Attention, découverte de la photo...
OHHHHHH
*Rires*
Je sais pas quoi faire!
Je sais pas quoi mettre!
Putain Merde !
*Rire sournois de Maxenss*
AH Il rigole de ce qu'il a mis hahahahaha
OH mec j'allais mettre un truc nul, si je cliquais sur entrée...
Ah ouais?
C'était la fin de ma carrière
*Exclamation* Arrêtes *Rires*
OHHH Oh nannn
*Sofyan* Ell est simple, voilà...
Elle est bien, elle est bien
*Rires*
*Sofyan* AH celle-là elle est propre!
Elle est pas mal celle-là !
*Rires extrêmes*
OUIIII OUIIII
C'est qui? C'est le tien!! (Sofyan) C'est la meilleure ( Maxenss)
AH LE BÂTARD !
Ohhh putain ohhh
J'ai l'impression que je suis nul ahh j'me sens nul!
Mais arrêteuuuh Maxenss
J'te jure c'est nul!
Bon écoute, on fera..Si tu veux on fera un tipee pour toi dans la description
*Rires*
Pour que tu puisses aller acheter deux/trois impros...
Qui a mit ça?? C'est toi?
*Rires*
C'est toi!
*Rires extravagants*
C'est très fort! C'est toi?
C'est moi ouais..
PAS MAL! Pas mal...
*Rires*
AHHHH Celle-là elle est géniale!
C'est toi? C'est toi mec?
Elle allait très bien mec!
Pour moi c'était l'idée ÉVIDENTE
C'était euh "Ah nanan  j'ai plus de jambes"
'Fin...
OUI NON
C'est très bizarre...
C'EST TRÈS BIZARRE
WOW
Putain!
Mais c'est que de la connotation euh...
Non! attendez, zehdiezhuaiz non on peut pas faire ça...
Vous pouvez faire de l'humour noir de ouf hein!
Vous avez le droit hein!
*Rires*
OUIII !
Qui a mit ça?!
C'est moi HAHAHA
Putain c'est drôle!
OHHHHH
*rires*
Elle est bien ou pas?
*Seb qui lit*
*Rires*
AH Je l'avais fait! Je l'avais fait dans la vidéo d'avant!
Je l'avais fait dans la vidéo...
*Rires extrêmes*
C'est une belle photo!
Qui a mit ça?!
*Seb lol*
OHHHHHH
*bruit chelou de Maxenss*
Pourquoi tu ris?
À chaque fois j'ai des idées trop nulles !
*Rires*
HAHAHAHAHHA
*Voix suraigue* Qui a fait ça?!
*Rires*
OHHHHHHHHHHH
Ah l'batard!
Fantastique
FANTASTIQUE
C'était, c'était digne des plus grands
OH LES MECS ATTENTION
Oh nan
ONAN
Humour noir ou pas?
Bah mec est ce que
Est ce que t'es pas obligé là de faire de l'humour noir?!
Ouais c'est chaud un peu!
*Rires*
Mec, là un moment euh...
*Sofyan qui lit*
Qui a dit ça?
Celle-là..elle est pas mal
C'est toi Maxenss?
Non Non
*Rires intensifs*
Très très bon ça, Très très drôle!
*Rires*
C'était marrant franchement la mienne (?! incomprehension désolée)
BRAVO BRAVO *Clap clap*
Les amis, je propose la belle.
ALLEZ Vas-y c'est bon, la dernière!
La meilleure.
Celui qui gagne celle-ci, il a tout gagné.
Allez, c'est bon
Enleve ça là, enleve ça
On va la mettre en jeu, on la met sur le micro
HAHAHA
Très bonne idée
Attends on va la foutre là, hop voilà...
*Rires*
Okay, ça peut être drôle, ça peut être drôle, ça peut être drôle...
OKAY
C'est super nul, j'ai pleins d'idées, je sais pas..
Pareil, je suis partagé! J'suis partagé...
*Rires enfouis de maxenss*
Roh putain, vas-y prête moi s'te plaît j'ai honte, j'ai honte
Prête moi ton t-shirt!
ALLLLEZZZZ
C'est toi?
OOO
Putain tu t'es chauffé!
*Rires immenses*
OHHHHHH *Rires*
'Tain !!
OHHHH On est chaud là, on est chaud là!
PUTAIN Nan, j'ai envie d'en refaire là je suis déçu!
Il est bien il est bien il est bien!
Ouaiiiiis
Alors le mien c'est le pire de...Que j'ai jamais mis
OHHHHH
QUI A MIT ÇA?!!
*Rires*
C'est toi frère c'est dans son Ficello (wut)
Whoua tu t'es chauffé!
DE OUF!
Pas drôle mais propre.
*Pouffement* (oui)
WHOUAAA
Whoua j'ai aucune idée!
*Lucas se cache* *De honte*
*Rires*
"AÏCHA AÏCHA" quoi!
"C'est cool l'humour aussi" *Rires*
*Rires extrêmes*
Le "PUTAIN JE SUIS NUL MERDE"
Ah c'est trop drôle!
Les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo!
On peut s'applaudire bien joué à tous!
*clap clap clap clap CLAP CLAP CLAP EBGZUFGKZEHFLKZEHFDLKZEJLZ*
J'espère qu'elle vous a plue, si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à l'aimer comme d'habitude!
N'hésitez pas!
ET surtout, ça faites-le,
A allez voir la chaîne de Maxenss
Allez voir la chaîne de Sofyan
Allez voir la chaîne de seb LA FRITE
TOUS les liens sont dans la description
Et ça s'affichera aussi dans l'outro!
Ils font des très bonnes vidéos
C'est vrai?
C'est vrai! C'est pas...C'est pas faux!
NANNN pas spécialement...
Nan pas ouf?
Des fois, des fois...
Des fois c'est cool!
Moi j'aime bien!
OUAIS OUAIS?! Moi j'aime bien ouais!
OUAIS OUAIS
Les amis, en exclusivité,
Vous pouvez faire une dédicace à...à votre collège si vous voulez.
ALORS EUH COLLÈGE EUH...
*Regards de panique*
Et voilà c'est fini!
HAHAHHAHAHAH
ÇA REFLETAIT BIEN LA VIDÉO OU PAS?!
*Rires*
On finit sur le nouveau mot de fin de toutes mes vidéos
3, 4...
YOUUUUUU
HAN T'as tout gaché...